defending his own pawns he's trying to
go active now not just that as kings as
well
just take a look white king can make a
bee line towards the center and start
attacking
vulnerable pawns yeah i yeah
nice technique there from artemis he's
fixed all of black's pawns on dark
squares
so those pawns on dart squares will be
easy pickings for the white bishop later
on
and uh okay he attacks black's bishop
next move white's king is going to enter
the center
what do you think winning for white
winning on the board at least yeah
winning
on the board okay in terms of club time
tamiya has one and a half
to uh hikaru is just under one minute
and 15 seconds nice move by artemiev
he offers a rook trade if the rooks come
off white is just winning white's king
is better than the black king
it's happened no chance now for nakamura
king takes porn
yep he's a pawn down white king is way
better than the black king
this is just easy for white and with
more than a minute on the clock this
should be
sufficient black's king can not do
anything white's king is going after
that born as well he's about to be two
pawns up take that pawn trade it off
yeah and uh and uh yeah look how quick
suddenly our tamiya is he's working up
our tamif on the clock
he's 20 seconds up as well no chance for
nakamura
no he's going to be regretting choosing
the black pieces now
it took him too long to defend and i'm
unable to defend on the board
and on the clock not working either
okay all i need to do is step his pawn
forward at the right moment he uses his
king first
nakamura resigns i'll tell me if it's
through to the semi-final
wow what a quarter final match between
these two that was
so intense